for eight seasons on showtime we thought
dexter was one wrong move from getting
caught but he always got away
and now the vigilante serial killer is
coming back for more
pull on some latex gloves and dig into
some of the juiciest facts about
showtime's gruesome
hit series from outlander to game of
thrones and the vampire diaries
plenty of hit tv shows are based on
popular series of books
and dexter is no different but while
those other examples are all extensions
of wildly best-selling books
the dexter series wasn't as well known a
title when it was selected for
adaptation
executive producer sarah colleton
decided to take a chance on developing
the series
when she came across jeff lindsay's
first dexter based crime novel
darkly dreaming dexter oddly she hadn't
even read the book before she started
working on getting it made into a tv
series
on an episode of sundance channels the
writer's room collarton revealed that
she was simply intrigued by a review of
the book she read
in the new yorker in 2004. it said it
was a
likable vigilante serial killer who had
an
ordinary jonas about him the first
season of dexter is inspired by the
novel
which similarly follows a miami
bloodspatter analyst named dexter
morgan who secretly murders horrible
criminals after being taught to do so by
his ex-cop foster father
but the show's writers used up most of
the material from the first book in the
pilot episode
meaning that the show and the source
material started veering away from each
other
very early on lindsay ultimately wrote
eight dexter novels which only bear a
passing resemblance to their tv cousin
the michael c hall playing dexter morgan
just might be his signature role the one
for which he's best and most remembered
but before he started pretending to be a
renegade dealer of death
hall had won attention and an emmy award
nomination
for his role as second generation
mortician david fisher
on hbo's funeral home drama six feet
under
halls said on an episode of sundance
channel's the writer's room
that he saw the dexter pilot script just
a few months after he finished up his
five-year run on six feet under
he wasn't interested in another show and
certainly not one thematically similar
to his previous one the last thing i
thought i'd do was another television
series
i didn't want to make another open-ended
commitment to uh
character and you're just surrounded by
dead bodies
but after reading the script a novel it
was based off of he ultimately decided
that it was too good of a part to pass
up
christian camargo portrayed the primary
villain in the first season of dexter
a fellow serial killer known as the ice
truck killer
but for that part co-executive producer
michael questa had a different guy in
mind
jeremy renner at the time best known for
playing serial killer jeffrey dahmer
in the 2002 movie dharma rena later said
in an interview with cloture club that
he rejected cuesta's offer
saying i can't do any other serial
killer movies or tv shows he almost took
the role anyway but had a scheduling
conflict with 28 weeks later
writers name their characters for lots
of different reasons
sometimes they just like the name it
suits a character or just rolls well off
the tongue
but other times character names can hold
a multi-lingual web of intrigue full of
secrets
easter eggs and hidden meanings and
that's the case with dexter
in latin dexter isn't generally a first
name but rather a word and it means
right or right
handed the latin word for the left hand
is sinister
dexter certainly has a sinister side
what with all the secret murders
he often refers to this side of himself
as the dark passenger
the nickname he gives to the side of his
personality that drives him to kill
taking the metaphor all the way home
then dexter would be the normal
personality that the character presents
to others
dexter is a bloody violent and
disturbing tv show
and it fits right in on a premium cable
channel and yet for a brief period
it actually ran on a broadcast network
in 2007
and 2008 the writers guild of america
went on strike for more than three
months
with more than 60 scripted television
series shutting down production
as a result of the strike the big
networks were left with major holes in
their tv schedules
with relatively tame crime and cop shows
like csi and criminal minds benched
cbs pulled content from its corporate
sibling showtime
all 12 episodes from the first season of
dexter aired in a carefully edited form
which reportedly marked the first time
in tv history that a broadcast channel
aired a whole season of a premium cable
series
two people in the cast of dexter found
love amidst the show's dark premise
michael c hall and jennifer carpenter
who played dexter's adoptive sister
deborah morgan
the general public didn't even know the
two have been a couple for more than a
year and a half until they showed up at
the golden globes in january 2009
having eloped and gotten married just a
few days prior
but the marriage wasn't meant to last
just about three years later
paul and carpenter released a statement
to entertainment weekly
announcing that they had separated and
were filing for divorce
it was evidently an amicable enough
split that hall and carpenter continued
to work with each other on dexter for a
few more years
still art managed to imitate life when
dexter writers explored a romantic
relationship
between the brother and sister awkward
well probably but the actors handled it
like prose
over the course of 96 episodes dexter
morgan killed a lot of people
but how many lives did the character
take in total the authors of the
dexter's kill list page on a dexter fan
site
carefully watched all episodes and tally
the number of victims
by both counting up who he killed on
screen and looking at the number of
blood slides he kept in his box of
souvenirs all in all
dexter had something to do with the
death of at least 168 people
a lot of those killings occurred within
the time frame of 2006 to 2013 when
dexter originally
aired if dexter had been a real person
he would have been one of the most
prolific murderers in the history of
miami
if not the whole world deb i'm the bay
harbour butcher
on the ground down on the ground during
the same period as the show the real
miami witnessed between 59 and 79
murders annually
proportionally this would make dexter
single-handedly responsible for 15 to 20
percent
of all the city's murders showtime's
dexter isn't the first screen adaptation
of a book about a handsome and
unflappable young man
whose demeanor hides a penchant for
brutal murder in 1991
brett east and ellis published american
psycho his cult classic that satirized
materialistic 80s culture
and centered around an investment banker
and probable serial killer named patrick
bateman
in 2000 christian bale portrayed bateman
in the film version of american psycho
and references to the character and book
he appears in have popped up throughout
dexter
dexter uses several aliases in his
criminal activities
and he buys animal tranquilizers under
the name patrick
bateman md when he schedules an
appointment with a therapist he's
investigating
dexter says his name is sean ellis
that's another american psycho reference
in the book patrick bateman's brother is
named sean and ellis is obviously the
author
of the book despite the loving tributes
ellis apparently isn't a dexter fan
in 2012 he tweeted a blunt review of the
series writing
dexter sucks big time a high concept qc
serial killer drama
that has as much depth and scares as an
episode of american
psycho 2. in the midst of filming the
fourth season of dexter in 2009
star michael c hall received some
devastating news
doctors diagnosed him with hodgkin's
lymphoma a type of cancer that attacks
the immune system
paul didn't take any time off of work
nor did he announce his situation to the
dexter cast or crew
instead he kept up with the rigors of
filming the showtime drama
and then received his first chemotherapy
treatment for cancer the day after
filming had wrapped for the season
in 2014 after the series initial run had
wrapped
hall spoke about his sinking at the time
in an interview with the guardian
saying i thought well i can treat this
successfully and if my hair falls out
i'll wear a wig during the fifth season
and i won't even have to share with
anyone that this is happening hall's
hair did fall out and when he attended
the 2010 golden globes and screen actors
guild awards he did so with a knick-kapp
on his head he didn't initially intend
to reveal his diagnosis to the public
but when he did he didn't regret it he
told the guardian
i'm glad i did because i really
underestimated how much that would be a
source of inspiration or strength to
other people
just to see someone who you know and
spend time watching who goes through the
treatment process successfully is of
value
michael c hall prepared for his role of
dexter by doing something right out of
the dexter playbook
identifying and stalking his potential
victims before shooting on the series
began
hall did some traditional preparation
for the role watching documentaries and
reading books about serial killers
but he still felt like he needed to feel
what being a stalking predator
searching for their prey might be like
paul said on george drombolopolis
tonight
i would go out by myself in new york and
try to find someone who was also
alone maybe go to a restaurant with a
bar and i would watch them finish their
meal
and endow them with all kinds of
reprehensible characteristics
a potential victim for dexter i wasn't
going to actually do anything
and i would i would see what it felt
like to follow them a little bit
then hall would quietly but intensely
follow his target through the streets of
new york
seemingly doing everything a real killer
would do except
well really killing i was raised with a
certain set of principles
in a tragic case of life imitating art
the fictional murders committed by
dexter morgan
may have led to real-life killings in
2009
indiana teenager andrew conley turned
himself into the police
and admitted strangling his brother to
death he claimed to have thought about
killing for years and felt a kinship
with dexter morgan
for feeling compelled to do so in 2014
an english teenager reportedly very into
dexter
stabbed his girlfriend to death then
disposed of the body
with tree trimming tools he soon
thereafter confessed to his sister that
his own dark passenger had compelled him
to kill
there's also mark twitchell a dexter
devotee and aspiring filmmaker
who made a dexter-esque fan film and
posted as dexter morgan on social media
in 2011 twitter turned a film studio in
his garage into his own elaborate kill
room and lured an innocent man to his
violent death he was caught promptly and
convicted of first degree murder
in 2013 dexter ended its original run
with a much anticipated series finale
would his crimes finally catch up to him
not exactly
instead dexter abandoned his only child
buried his sister at sea
faked his death and started life over
under an assumed identity as a
lumberjack
in the pacific northwest that's
disappointing
it wasn't just fans who wanted dexter to
face some kind of consequences
after eight years of getting away with
them many members of the series creative
team
wanted more closure with the ending as
well after the season 8 finale in 2013
dexter producer john goldwyn told
vulture they won't let us kill him
showtime was very clear about that when
we told them the arc for the last season
they
just said just to be clear he's going to
live in an interview with e news
former dexter showrunner clyde phillips
revealed what he would have done if he'd
been in charge of crafting the show's
final scene
he said in the very last scene of the
series dexter wakes up
dexter's opening his eyes and he's on
the execution table at the florida
penitentiary
they're just starting to administer the
drugs and he looks out through the
window to the observation gallery and in
the gallery are all the people that
dexter killed as phillips conceived it
the observers would have been everyone
who ever died as a result of dexter's
actions
from the trinity killer to laguardia and
doakes to his minor kills of the week
a lot of people didn't like the way
dexter wrapped up no matter how you feel
about it
it's hard to argue that this would have
been one hell of a way to go
the silver lining of keeping dexter
alive was always that the show could one
day see a revival
and get a second chance to wrap things
up in a satisfying way
now that do-over is finally coming to
pass in 2020 seven years after dexter
aired his last episode
showtime ordered 10 new episodes to be
presented as a limited series
michael c hall signed on to once again
play dexter while the series original
executive producer clyde phillips
agreed to serve a showrunner in april
2021
showtime unveiled a teaser trailer for
the revival and announced that it would
air the following fall
plot details have initially been scarce
but reports indicate that the episodes
will find dexter morgan hiding out under
the assumed identity of jim lindsey
in the small town of iron lake new york
there a mystery will ensnare the mayor
the chief of police
and the true crime podcast host as well
as dexter morgan
back from the dead to kill again
dexter's dark passengers still with him
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you